[Musik]
was kann und muss Migrationspolitik
leisten und was vielleicht auch nicht
eine Frage die häufig und heftig
diskutiert wird in Deutschland und wir
freuen uns auf Ihre Antworten Rut kopmn
Soziologe und Migrationsforscher hier in
Berlin herzlich Willkommen zu phöniix
persönlich ja danke für die Einladung
freue mich Herr KMZ die Zahlen für 2023
liegen im Moment auf dem Tisch das sind
Schätzungen für die dieses Jahr nach der
etwa eine Million Asylanträge gestellt
werden in Europa aber auch in Norwegen
und der Schweiz rund 300 000 rechnet man
da aus für Deutschland glauben sie wir
können das auch noch
schaffen wenn es das alleine wäre wäre
es ja schaffbar aber wir haben bereits 1
Million ukrainische Flüchtlinge im Land
und das natürlich
zusammengezählt bringt uns auf Zahlen
die durchaus einzigartig sind also so
viele Flüchtlinge auf einmal hatten W
noch nie in der Nachkriegszeit viele
schauen jetzt auch mit Sorge auf den
Nahen Osten nach dem schrecklichen
Terrorangriff der Hamas gegen Israel
viele befürchten das wird sich zu einem
Flächenbrand ausweiten was würden Sie
denken was wird das für Fluchtbewegung
in Richtung Europa bedeuten na ist
natürlich schwer vorher zu sagen aber
was man vorher sagen kann dass wenn es
da zu Fluchtbewegung kommt dass wir
dafür völlig ungewappnet sind völlig
unvorbereitet sind im Sinne dass wir
immer noch ein Asylrecht haben dass uns
solchen Fluchtbewegungen ausliefert und
uns auch Versuche von Staaten um Europa
herum um
Fluchtbewegung zu nutzen um Druck auf
die EU auszuüben auch schutzlos
ausgeliefert sind also sind verschiedene
Szenarien möglich
aber wenn es zu größeren Fluchtbewegung
aus dem gaserstreifen heraus oder auch
aus dem Libanon heraus wenn es dorthin
überschwappen würde kommen würde dann
wird sich natürlich ein Teil ein Teil
von diesen Menschen wird dann nach
Europa weiterziehen wollen auch weil die
arabischen Nachbarstaaten nicht
unbedingt dafür bekannt sind dass sie
die Palästinenser sehr willkommen heißen
ähm und es wird natürlich Staaten geben
im arabischen Raum Tunesien Ägypten äh
Syrien äh oder auch die Türkei oder auch
Russland und Belarus die ein Interesse
daran haben
Migranten zu nutzen um Druck auf die EU
auszuüben also es ist völlig ein
plausibles Szenario dass
Belarus und Russland versuchen werden
Flüchtlinge an die europäischen Grenzen
zu zu locken dadurch Druck auf die EU
auszu auszuüben Osteuropa zu
destabilisieren eine Keile zu zu zu
zu stellen zwischen Osteuropa und und
Westeuropa
all das ist möglich der tunesische
Präsident Kais ist auch unberechenbar
wenn die tunesische Bevölkerung sich
hinter den Palästinenser stellen würde
dann hätte auch er ein Interesse dran
durch das das an körbeln von
Migrationsströme den Druck auf die EU zu
erhöhen also und das alles sind wir
wirklich schutzlos ausg liiefer solchen
Erpressungsversuchen weil das Asylrecht
wie wir es haben immer noch so ist dass
jer der es an ein europäischen
Außengrenze schafft ein Recht auf ein
Asylantrag in Europa hat darum auch
reingelassen werden muss und das gilt
sogar und das wird dann auch sogar
gelten wenn Menschen aus Gasa fliehen
dann wird's darunter auch viele Hamas
Sympathisanten geben auch die haben
unter den jetzigen Bedingungen ein
uneingeschränktes einreiserecht in die
Europäische Union und wenn wir uns jetzt
Sorgen machen über Ausschreitung und
Sympathie kundung
für den Hamas Angriff auf deutschen
Straßen dann muss man sich auch Sorgen
machen äh wenn ein Teil der Menschen die
solche Taten unterstützen
noch als zusätzliche Zuwanderer dazu
kommen also wir müssen uns wappnen und
wir müssen unser Asylsystem ändern in
der Tat schauen wir im Moment
fassungslos auf Hamas Sympathisanten die
auf deutschen Straßen den Mord an
Israelis feiern die die fahen verbrennen
free Palestine
rufen
ähm und fragen uns was sind das für
Leute und wir sind die ins Land gekommen
haben sie dazu Erkenntnisse na das sind
sind heterogen zusammengesetzte Gruppen
also in erster Linie soll man auch nicht
vergessen es gibt auch noch ein
erheblicher Teil dieser pro Hamas
Demonstranten die überhaupt kein
Migrationshintergrund haben sondern aus
der linksautonomen animperialistischen
szhne stammen die mit Migration nichts
zu tun haben
die gibt's auch noch auf der rechten
übrig übrigens ne da gibt's auch Hamas
Sympathisanten aber tatsächlich ein
erheblicher Teil hat ein migrationsh
Hintergrund stammt aus der Türkei stammt
aus arabischen Ländern teilweise
flüchtlingshintergrund teilweise ist es
auch die zweite dritte Generation der
Gastarbeiter Migranten also das ist
schon heterogenes
Gemisch aber es ist eine es ist eine ein
Problem eine Gefahr die es schon seit
vielen Jahren gibt also solche äh Anti
israelischen antijüdischen Ausschreitung
gibt schon seit vielen Jahren am
akutstag und so weiter es wird auch von
vielen inklusive mir selbst auch schon
seit Jahren Gewand gewarnt für den
virulenten Antisemitismus unter ein
erheblicher Teil der muslimischen
Gemeinschaften
in Deutschland und in Europa und diese
Warnungen sind über Jahre hinweg in den
Wind geschlagen worden und stattdessen
wurden die Menschen die gewarnt haben
als Rassisten und islamophoben
deformiert also da ist die die die
deutsche äh islampolitik
völligelgeleitet gewesen in der
Vergangenheit man hat geredet mit
Verbänden von dem man jetzt sagt warum
verurteilen die nicht Klippen klar jetzt
die diese diese grultaten des Hamas
Hamas das sind die gleichen Leute die
schon seit Jahren eingeladen werden bei
jeder feierveranstaltung in den
Deutschen Islamkonferenz den von vom
deutschen Staat sozusagen eine eine
Rolle zu zugeschieben wird die wden auf
dem Podest gestellt als seien sie die
Vertreter der musl in Deutschland es
gibt viele Muslime die von diesen
Organisationen gar nicht vertreten
werden und die hören wir nicht also der
Staat hat da völlig versagt wo sie schon
die Muslime ansprechen ist es trotzdem
so dass viele sich darüber wundern warum
von den sage ich friedlichen Liberalen
aufgeklärten Muslim jetzt nicht ein
Aufschrei ertönt wie erklären Sie sich
das na ja es gibt es gibt Muslime die
sich durchaus aussprechen er Gin z.B von
der alhamra Gesellschaft hat sich in
vielen Interviews sehr klar
ausgesprochen und es gibt andere
Beispiele Sheran atesch es könnte do
viele andere nennen das Problem äh ist
dass diese Menschen äh in der Politik
und in der Öffentlichkeit bisher nicht
äh äh die Rolle äh zugeschrieben
bekommen haben die sie verdienen
stattdessen haben wir mit den Islamisten
und den Rechtsextremisten im
muslimischen Lager äh gesprochen und den
tion Subventionsgelder zukommen lassen
den mit Verantwortlichkeit gegeben für
die Ausbildung von Imame oder für den
islamischen Religionsunterricht also wir
haben völlig auf die
falschen gewettet ich meine den
Zentralrat der Muslime in Deutschland
z.B ich meine
miligürüch ich meine ATIP der die größte
mitgliedsgesellschaft von vom Zentralrat
der Muslime alsoan masiek der sagt immer
in der Öffentlichkeit ja ja wenn es
nicht um Israel geht sagte immer
tolerante und Sachen won man denkt ja ja
ja aber einan masiek vertritt eine
Organisation in dem das islamische
Zentrum Hamburg der deutsche Vertreter
des iranischen Mul Regimes Mitglied ist
in dem ATIP die größte rechtsextreme
Organisation Deutschlands laut
Verfassungsschutz das größte Mitglied
ist und schon seit Jahrzehnten den den
vizevorsitzen stellt warum stellen Sie
nicht den vorsitzen weil einal mas masik
ist ein schönes Aushängeschild der ist
vor den Konsum der deutschen
Mehrheitsgesellschaft gedacht
und und und es klingt ihn auch aber nur
durch die Mithilfe von den großen
politischen Parteien das gilt sowohl für
die CDU CSU als auch für die
SPD die haben es ihn ermöglicht
sozusagen als ein ein ein verdaubares
Aushängeschild zu fungieren für
Organisationen die überhaupt nicht
demokratisch und tolerant sind aber wenn
wir das jetzt so stehen lassen Herr
Kopmann verunlimpfen wir dann nicht
automatisch auch wenn sie sagen der
Zentralrat der Muslime sehr viele
Menschen sehr viele Muslime die genauso
entsetzt darüber sind was in Israel
passiert ist wie jetzt
beispielsweise weiß ich nicht Christen
andere Religionszugehörigkeiten und so
weiter na ja man muss erstmal
unterscheiden zwischen den Verbänden und
den einzelnen Muslimen also diese
Verbände also sicherlich der Zentralrat
der Muslime in Deutschland vertritt nur
ein ganz ganz winziger Teil der Muslime
die in Deutschland leben andere Verbände
haben größere Anhängerschaften dietip
miligorische und so weiter das sind
durchaus nicht wenige aber sind auch
nicht alle Muslime
ähm aber man muss schon auch verlangen
von den Muslimen die es dann anders
sehen dass sie sich dann auch hören
lassen dass sie es da nicht zulassen äh
dass nur diese Verbände für Sie sprechen
oder äh dass sie auch etwas dagegen tun
wenn Sie sehen dass Muslime auf die
Straße gehen äh und offen
äh die Angriffe von Hamas feiern warum
gibt es die Gegenstimme nicht also ich
ich würde schon erwarten auch von
Muslimen in Deutschland die diese
Gewalttaten nicht mit mittragen und die
sich schämen äh für das was eine
Organisation wie samidun da in Neuköln
veranstaltet dass sie diesen Scham und
äh äh diese diese diese Ablehnung der
Gewalt auch zeigen auf unseren Straßen
war war warum sehen wir nur die falschen
Muslime warum sehen wir die guten nicht
das ist auch ein Vorwurf natürlich an an
die guten also wenn es meine Religion
wäre in in in in der Namen da Menschen
Kinder alte Holocaust Überlebende sogar
abgeschlachtet werde ich würde mich in
den Boden schämen und ich würde schon
auf die Straße gehen und das würde ich
schon auch gerne von meinen muslimischen
Mitbürgern sehen wollen wenn wir in
diesen Tagen immer wieder hören Israels
Sicherheit ist deutsche staatsreson und
wir schauen uns an
dass es auch z.B weitere Ankündigung für
Versammlung am Wochenende gibt viele
jüdische Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Deutschland fürchten inzwischen noch
vermehrt oder wieder vermehrt um ihre
Sicherheit es war in den letzten Monaten
und Jahren ohnehin schon schwieriger
geworden welche Handhabe hat denn der ne
deutsche Staat dann was würden Sie sagen
na ja sie kann natürlich bestimmte
Organisationen verbieten die sie schon
längst hätte verbieten sollen die ja
offen amass unterstützen und nicht erst
jetzt schon seit langem zum Glück hat
der bundesglanzer auch entschieden jetzt
samidun verbieten zu
lassen aber ein ganz wichtiges
Instrument das die Bundesregierung aber
auch Länderregierungen und Kommunen
haben ist mit wem redet man wen lässt
man Subventionen zukommen wen wertet man
auf indem man sie einlät bei
Veranstaltungen bei Feierlichkeiten und
wen wertet man ab indem man sie nicht
einlät das das hat mit dann braucht man
keine Organisation zu Verboten zu
verbieten das sind auch keine Eingriffe
in die
Religionsfreiheit aber dass man mit
bestimmten
Organisationen nicht reden sollte oder
zumindest sie nicht aufwerten sollte
indem man sie z.B Rechte gibt wie das
Recht Religionsunterricht zu geben das
Recht mitzureden über imamausbildung wie
bei dem Zentralrat der Muslime z.B der
Fall ist das sind ganz wichtige
Instrumente mit dem ein Staat Steuern
kann welche Teile der muslimischen
Gemeinschaft man aufwertet und sichtbar
macht und auf der anderen Seite auch
welche man dann nicht sichtbar macht und
bisher hat man die liberale Muslime in
in Stich gelassen nun ist es ja in den
letzten Tagen durchaus so gewesen dass
nach der sag jetzt mal so lapida
Klatsche die die Bundesregierung
bekommen hat in den Wahlergebnissen
durch die Landtagswahlen am letzten
Wochenende durchaus auch in die
Diskussion Migrationspolitik
Bewegung gekommen ist es soll jetzt es
wird parteiübergreifend gesprochen es
soll eine Gesetzesreform in den
Bundestag kommen und nach all dem
was wir hören ist ein ganz zentraler
Punkt die Abschiebepolitik der
Bundesregierung bzw Deutschlands äh die
denn doch verschärft werden soll äh aus
den Maßnahmen die von denen Sie gehört
haben welche würden Sie denn als
effektivste
bezeichnen na ja all diese Maßnahmen die
vorgeschlagen werden haben eine relativ
begrenzte Effektivität sie werden uns
alle keine Kontrolle über die irreguläre
Zuwanderung bieten warum nicht weil
erstmal die Zahl der Menschen die
sogenannt vollziehbar ausreiseepflichtig
sind in Deutschland sich auf einige
wenige glaub 20.000 oder sowas beläuft
oder 30 1000 das sind nicht viele
Menschen um die es geht das sind
Menschen diese 30.000 das sind Menschen
die schon seit Jahre eigentlich das Land
verlassen müssen in vielen Fällen und
warum gelingt es nicht oft weil die
Identitäten nicht geklärt sind weil es
keine Funktion funktionierende Abkommen
mit den Herkunftsländern gibt die
Maßnahmen die vorgeschlagen werden z.B
eine Verlängerung der abschieberhaft die
abschie die Verkürzung der Frist mit dem
eine eine Abschiebung äh und eine
Aufhebung der Duldung angekündigt werden
soll klar das wird schon etwas bringen
in einigen wenigen Fällen die man dann
vielleicht abschieben kann die
man Leuten jetzt die die Zeit
nutzen um abzutauchen
aber es wird ja es wird um einige
hunderte vielleicht wenn es hoch kommt
einige Tausende gehen aber das
Grundproblem dass wir keine Kontrolle
haben darüber wer über unsere
Außengrenzen und ich spreche jetzt über
die Außengrenzen der EU weil wenn Sie
einmal in der EU und in den grenzenlosen
Schengenraum sind dann haben wir auch
schon die Kontrolle über die deutschen
Grenzen verloren also das muss schon in
EU Außengrenzen passieren wir haben
keine Kontrolle darüber wer reinkommt es
kommen viele Menschen rein die kein
Anspruch auf ein Flüchtlings oder
Asylstatus haben wir schaffen es nicht
diese Menschen zurückzuführen in ihre
Herkunftsländer oder in den
Transitländern über die sie eingereist
sind und dieses Grundproblem bleibt
ungelöst viele wollen ja nach wie vor
nach Deutschland was würden Sie sagen im
europäischen Vergleich was macht
Deutschland so besonders attraktiv na ja
erstmal dass Deutschland natürlich ein
relativ wohlfahrendes Land ist auch ein
Land mit einem funktionierenden
Wohlfahrtstaat was nicht nur das wird
dann oft hervorgehoben dass der
Sozialhilfeniveau hier auf ein relativ
hohes Niveau ist aber ich glaub viel
wichtiger für viele Migranten ist noch
dass wir hier ein gut funktionierendes
Bildungssystem haben das zugänglich ist
für alle die Menschen die migrieren
denken auch an die Zukunft ihre Kinder
nachvollziehbar ja nachölllich
nachvollziehbar gesundheitsv Fürsorge
auch das auf einem relativen hohen Stand
in Deutschland plus auch das wieder für
alle zugänglich und gerade natürlich für
Migranten die meistens ein niedriges
Bildungsniveau haben auch ihre
Aussichten auf den Arbeitsmarkt sind
eher wenn sie schon Job bekommen eher
gering verdien da ist es für die
natürlich ganz wichtig dass Bildung
Gesundheit
hier
frei mehr oder weniger frei verfügbar
sind und dass wenn sie keine Arbeit
finden es auch noch ein soziales Netz
gibt also das ist das ist was
Deutschland attraktiv macht das ist
natürlich auch was Österreich attraktiv
macht oder Schweden oder die Niederlande
das teilt Deutschland mit vielen anderen
Ländern aber Deutschland ist halt ein
großes Land das hat dann auch noch einen
Namen in der Namen in der Welt natürlich
wer kennt schon Dänemark wer kennt schon
die Niederlande in Ghana ja na Ghana
vielleicht kennen die Niederlande noch
als ehemalige Kolonie aber sagen wir mal
in Nigeria da ist Deutschland schon ein
eine Marke sozusagen was sind ihre
Erfahrungen ihre Forschungsergebnisse
wenn potenzielle Flüchtlinge sage ich
jetzt mal also Leute die sich mit dem
Gedanken befassen ich verlasse mein Land
aus welchen Gründen auch immer mag jetzt
mal dahingestellt sein wie läuft da die
Informationspolitik gehen die gezielt
dann nach Deutschland informieren Sie
sich oder ist es mehr etwas wo man einem
Verwandten folgt also was sind da die
die Motive in die einzelnen Länder zu
gehen ja also die die Motivation zu
migrieren entsteht tatsächlich oft über
soziale Netzwerke Familienmitglieder
Menschen aus dem gleichen Dorf oder
Freunde die schon nach Europa gegangen
sind und die vor allem auch über soziale
Medien dann
berichte Videos Nachrichten und so
weiter
zurück nach Hause schicken und diese
Geschichten sind oft sehr positiv sie
sind natürlich auch erstmal dadurch
gefiltert dass nur diejenigen die es
dann nach Europa schaffen auch dann
diese Bilder zurückschicken aber ganz
ehrlich guck man ganz ganz kurz aber
wenn ich in einer turnalle sitze und ich
habe überhaupt keine Privatsphäre ich
muss mir meine sanitären Anlagen mit
ganz vielen Menschen teilen und so
weiter würden sie das dann als
attraktives Video bezeichnen das dieses
Video wird natürlich nicht ausgestraht
nach Hause geschickt also die die die
jungen Männer werden oft auf dem Weg
geschickt mit Geld von der Familie dass
sie dann die Menschenschmuggler geben
müssen natürlich und die Familien
erwarten auch dass Geld zurückkommt das
ist eine Investition von Familien oft in
Migration also die Menschen die dann
hier die jungen Männer die dann hier
ankommen und tatsächlich kein Job finden
und in ein Asylbewerberheim über Jahre
bleiben müssen die werden trotzdem alles
tun was sie können um Geld nach Hause zu
schicken Schwarzarbeit vielleicht auch
Kriminalität und auch sogar das Wenige
was sie bekommen an asylbewerbeleistung
da werden die noch von versuchen Geld
nach Hause zu schicken und auch die
Nachrichten die der Status der Familie
hängt auch von dem Erfolg des Migranten
ab also werden schöne Bilder nach Hause
geschickt man geht raus aus dem
asülbewerberheim mietet vielleicht für
ein Tag ein Auto oder ein Freund ein
Bekannter hat vielleicht ein schönes
Auto und lässt sich ablichten in einem
teuren Mercedes oder BMW dieses Bild
geht nach Hause und so wird das Bild
vermittelt von Migration als ein Erfolg
es wird auch
das Bild
vermittelt von Deutschland Europa als
Land von Milch und Honig äh und das
bringt natürlich dann wieder neue Leute
dazu sich auf dem Weg zu begeben wie
beurteilen sie denn in diesem
Zusammenhang dann die Diskussion um
Chipkarten statt Bargeld oder auch eine
Vorschlag der auf dem Tisch liegt der
Block dem Blockieren der transfergeld
Möglichkeit in die
Herkunftsländer na ja für Menschen die
natürlich anerkannt sind kann man jetzt
nicht blockieren dass sie Geld
zurückschicken aber was man tun kann
natürlich wenn Leute tatsächlich im
Asylverfahren sind und nicht oder nicht
anerkannt sind und geduldet sind
irgendwie noch in dieser Situation zwar
abgelehnt aber können nicht abgeschauben
werden ja dann wäre es eine gute Idee
finde ich um auf Chipkarten umzustellen
weil man damit es unmöglich macht Geld
zurückzuschicken in die Heimat es ist
immer für diese Menschen dann mit so
einer Chipkarte noch möglich frei zu
entscheiden woran sie
sozusagen ihr Geld ausgeben sie haben
das Geld S ist auch ihr Geld also in dem
Sinne genügt das auch alle anforder des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes dass den
Leuten ein ein ein ein ein ein
anständiges
Lebensniveau ermöglicht wird aber wenn
sich rumspricht natürlich in den
Heimatländern dass wenn man nach
Deutschland kommt dass man da eine
Chipkarte bekommt und da zwar dann
selbst anständig von leben kann aber
kein Geld an die Familie schicken kann
dann wird das schon
die Anreize um sich auf dem Weg zu
begeben
abnehmen lassen es wird natürlich auch
Nebenwirkung geben da muss man auch
ehrlich sein auf denjenigen die auf
diejenigen die schon hier sind
ja es wird eine die Anreize wegnehmen
für Menschen die sich auf dem Weg zu
begeben aber die die schon hier sind
sind immer noch unter den Druck der
Familien also sie werden was natürlich
jetzt auch schon passiert versuchen dann
über schwarzearbeit und Kriminalität
trotzdem Geld zurückzuschicken das da
muss man auch ehrlich sein wie bewerten
sie denn den kürzlich gefundenen EU
Asylrechts äh äh Gesetzesentwurf oder
die Reform die ja sagt wir lassen die
Flüchtlinge oder geflüchteten gar nicht
oder die auf dem Fluchtweg sind gar
nicht erst einreisen sondern lassen Sie
an den Außengrenzen und sie müssen ihre
Asylanträge an den Außengrenzen der EU
Stellen bringt das was
auf sich gestellt bringt es ganz wenig
weil das Problem der Rückführung damit
nicht gelöst wird man kann durch
grenzverfahren durchführen und sagen
innerhalb von 6ch Monate muss dann
vereststehen ob jemand in Europa ein
Asylantrag stellen kann oder nicht nicht
und werden abgelehnt da steht dann in
dem Abkommen dann werden die Menschen
zügig zurückgeführt die Frage ist
natürlich wohin weil wir haben keine
funktionierende Rückführungsabkommen
weder mit Transitstaaten noch mit
Herkunftsländern Transitstaaten sind die
Länder über die die Menschen in die EU
einreisen z.B die Türkei oder Tunesien
oder
Marokko die haben wir nicht und wir
wissen dass das der Grund ist warum die
Rückführung nicht funktioniert und die
wird auch nicht funktionieren mit diesen
Grenz fahren und dann droht sich sogar
eine Verschlimmbesserung äh zu ergeben
nämlich dass dann Menschen die abgelhnt
worden sind länger als diese sechs
Monate in diesen grenzlagern bleiben
müssen vielleicht über Jahre dort
bleiben müssten und dann kriegen
natürlich unhaltbare und letztendlich
inhumane Zustände die zu
vielen Morias an den europäischen
Außengrenzen führen werden also nur wenn
es Europa gelingt und da sollte
Deutschland aus meiner Sicht eine
Vorreiterrolle spielen wenn es Europa
gelingt funktionierende Abkommen äh mit
Drittstaaten zu schließen Drittstaaten
sind nicht Herkunftsstaaten sondern
andere Staaten die diese dann aufnehmen
na ja herkunftstaat Drittstaaten sind
erstmal nicht EU-Länder und da gibt's
verschiedene Arten von Drittstaaten es
gibt die Herkunftsländer also da könnte
man da braucht man Abkommen um Menschen
die abgelehnt werden zurückchicken zu
können aber man braucht auch Abkommen
wen man die Kontrolle über die
irreguläre Migration bekommen will und
die Kontrolle die brauchen wir auch aus
Sicherheitsgründen wir haben über die
Möglichkeiten ein Eskalation der
Konflikte im Nahen Osten gesprochen über
die Möglichkeiten der Erpressung durch
Diktatoren wie Erdogan lukasenko KIS und
so weiter wenn wir das unter Kontrolle
bekommen wollen dann brauchen wir auch
Abkommen mit Transitländern wie Tunesien
wie die Türkei damit wir auch Menschen
dort ihre Asylverfahren durchlaufen
lassen können die vielleicht
schon Fluchtgründe haben nicht nur
Menschen die abgelehnt worden sind hier
aber auch Menschen die einfach auf
Lampedusa ankommen oder auf die
griechischen Inseln dass wir sagen
können
wir bieten euch die Möglichkeit ein
Asylantrag zu stellen aber wenn ihr auf
irregulären Weg nach Europa kommt gibt
es diese Möglichkeit nicht in Europa
selbst sondern in andere Staaten mit
denen wir Abkommen haben und das können
natürlich sogar auch Länder sein die gar
nicht an Deutschland an Europa Grenzen
denänemark und Großbritannien die
überlegen sowas mit Ruanda zu machen ich
glaube da geäbe es bessere Partner als
Ruanda ehrlich gesagt Deutschland
verhandelt mit Tunesien relativ
erfolgreich erfolglos zur Zeit Erfolg
los ja genau das ist ein Transitland wo
es nicht so gut klappt aber es gibt zwei
andere Länder in Westafrika Ghana und
Senegal die schon seit sehr langer Zeit
auch von Deutschland als sichere
Herkunftsstaaten angesehen werden das
sind relativ stabile und relativ
demokratische Länder in Afrika ich würde
wenn ich es in der Regierung für sagen
hatte ich würde an erste Stelle mit mit
solchen Ländern verhandelen damit wir
das aber können müssen wir eine
Kleinigkeit ändern in der europäischen
Regelung nämlich das sogenannte
verbindungskriterium ist ein bisschen
technisch aber es ist sehr wichtig jetzt
ist es so dass wir nur Länder als
sichere Drittstaat benennen können mit
dem asylsuchen eine Verbindung haben
also über die die eingereist sind oder
wo die Familien Mitglieder haben also
Dänemark und Großbritannien können das
tun weil die sind nicht Teil des
gemeinsamen europäischen Asylsystems
Deutschland kann es nicht die EU als
ganze kann es auch nicht weil wir dieses
komische verbindungskriterium haben ist
kein Menschenrecht hat mit
Menschenrechten gar nichts zu tun das
sollte man streichen dann kann man mit
anständigen und verlässlicheren Partnern
aus Tunesien reden mit gana und Senegal
wenn es einmal so ist dass Menschen die
irregulär über das Mittelmeer kommen
wissen dass sie nicht die Möglichkeit
bekommen in Europa Asylantrag zu zu
stellen sondern in Land vegana dann
werden die meisten auch nicht kommen
ganz wichtig ist da natürlich schon dass
wir das nicht als Europa nutzen um uns
unsere humanitären Verpflichtungen zu
entziehen sondern dass wir dann
Flüchtlinge auf eine andere Art und
Weise aufnehmen und zwar legal
kontrolliert und für die Flüchtlinge
sicher und das ist über sogenannte
kontingentlösung kann man mit der unacr
zusammenmachchen in dem direkt Menschen
aus den Flucht und Konfliktregion
aufnimmt sicher mit Flugzeug nach Europa
bringt die Menschen wissen von Tag 1
dass Sie hier über längere Zeit bleiben
können dass sie hier ein sicheren Status
bekommen Asylverfahren kann man
abschaffen das ganze nur noch für
Menschen die aus Nachbarländer kommen
müsste man eine Ausnahme machen
und auch die Bevölkerung das ist ganz
wichtig die weiß auch die Menschen die
hierherkmen das sind alles Flüchtlinge
die tatsächlich ein Schutzbedarf haben
wir können eine Sicherheitsprüfung dann
durchführen in den Herkunftsregionen
Länder wie Kanada oder Australien machen
das auch so wir haben kein wir wissen
nicht wer reinkommt wenn da ein großes
Konflikt
jetzt draus werden große Zahlen von
Palästinenser sich auf dem Weg begen wie
können wir feststellen wie können wir
absichern dass keine hamasanhänge äh in
die Europäische Union reinkommen unter
dem herrschensystem können wir das nicht
überhaupt nicht nur wenn wir eine
sicherheitsprüfung durchführen wde
würden bevor wir Menschen Zustimmung
geben in die EU einzureisen hätten wir
diese Kontrolle über die Anzahl und auch
über diese Sicherheitsfrage Herr km wie
wir beide auch gerade jetzt wieder sehen
eine sehr komplexe Materie sie haben ein
Buch geschrieben lotterieasyl heißt das
Quatsch asylotterie Entschuldigung
da entwickeln sie einen Dreiklang wo sie
sagen drei effektive Maßnahmen die
Zusammenwirken würde Erfolg bringen mit
der Bitte um eine kurze Antwort können
Sie uns da ein kurzes Fazit
ziehen ja es ist erstens die irreguläre
Migration
zurückdringen das geht mit Abkommen mit
Drittstaaten wo Asylverfahren
durchgeführt werden also Menschen in
irregulär nach Europa kommen über das
Mittelmeer können also können haben das
haben nach wie vor das Recht der fyl
aber das wird
gewährleistet in Drittstaaten im
Gegenzug nimmt Europa Menschen direkt
aus den Konfliktregionen auf über
Kontingente aus meiner Sicht kann man
das in der gleichen Umfang machen wie
wir bisher Flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben
aber dann gut verteilt über die Zeit
vorhersagbar das Z damit z.B auch die
Kommunen und die Länder Wissen nächstes
Jahr müssen wir so und so viele
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen und die werden aus
diesem und diese diese Länder kommen
dann wissen wir was wir machen müssen
wir können uns darauf vorbereiten
kitaitaplätze bereitstellen Lehre
bereitstellen ärstliche Versorgung
bereitstellen und so weiter und so fort
und damit wäre auch
die Polarisierung
in der Asylpolitik den Boden entzogen
weil die Polarisierung geht nicht darum
dass die Menschen in Deutschland nicht
bereit sind Flüchtlinge zu helfen sie
machen sich Sorgen darüber dass wir
keine Kontrolle darüber haben wie viele
Menschen reinkommen und welche Menschen
reinkommen und dass wir es nicht
schaffen die Menschen die kein Recht auf
Asyl haben auch tatsächlich
zurückzuführen das sind die Probleme
und dann braucht man noch eine kleine
Lösung für eine ganz spezielle Gruppe
die wir jetzt oft auch gar nicht helfen
also was ich noch sagen sollte zu den
Kontingenten nicht unwichtig dass wir
damit Menschen helfen können die jetzt
keine Chance haben in unserem Asylsystem
das sind erstmal die Frauen äh die
älteren äh die Menschen mit Verletzungen
oder die Kranken weil wir verlangen von
Menschen dass sie einen einen langen und
gefährlichen und davinistischen
Hindernislauf auf sich nehmen ihr Leben
riskieren und viel Geld ausgeben um
überhaupt in Europa zu gelangen viele da
bleiben auf der Strecke buchstäblich
inem sie sterben andere haben einfach
nicht die Möglichkeiten sich auf dem Weg
zu begeben es gibt auch Länder wo
Menschen nicht rauskommen Yemen z.B all
diese Menschen könnte man über
Kontingente helfen und dann gibt's noch
eine Restgruppe von Menschen die
individuell politisch verfolgt werden
das sind eigentlich diejenigen für für
die unser Grundgesetz Artikel 16A
ähäh gemeint ist dieser Artikel wird
jetzt kaum beansprucht weil kaum ein ein
Dissident oder politisch verfolgt
schafft
nach Europa zu zu zu gelangen da müssten
wir die Möglichkeit haben für sogenannte
humanitäre visesen sass solche Menschen
bei europäischen Botschaften überall auf
der Welt ein Antrag auf ein humanitäres
Visum stellen können mit dem sie dann
nach Europa einreisen können äh und dort
Asyl beantragen können also eine
riesendebatte mit vielen Facetten und
vor allen Dingen auch vielen Emotionen
Herr Kopmann herzlichen Dank dass Sie
uns ein bisschen Klarheit in die
Begrifflichkeiten gebracht haben danke
ihnen fürs Gespräch
danke